welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Thunderbolts news update alert an
update from a Marvel Studios executive
confirms that the upcoming Thunderbolts
movie will serve as a sequel to the 2021
Black Widow film but why like why is a
Thunderbolts project suited as a sequel
to that film specifically and what are
the loose threads left behind in Black
Widow that makes the upcoming
Thunderbolts Project A fitting
continuation of that narrative let's
look at those Clues together speculation
Nation but like always my beautiful nerd
babies head on over to nerdriot.shop the
new home of the new rockstars merch
where you can get one of our newest
Ant-Man the WASP Quantum Mania shirts I
love these shirts times a million so
much so get one for yourself over at
nerd riot.shop today alright so Marvel
Studios art director Andy Park recently
revealed via Zuckerberg's instagram.com
the upcoming Thunderbolts film will be a
sequel to Black Widow starring Scarlett
Johansson and Nirvana a little bit
and while some people on the internet
might be confused as to why I honestly
feel like it makes a good amount of
sense and there's a couple of reasons
why a first of which is the fact that
the Thunderbolts film will include the
return of secretary Thaddeus Ross as
played by Harrison Ford who's taking
over the role for the late William Hurt
whose last MCU appearance was in that
black widow movie as Secretary of State
Ross was hunting down Natasha Romanov
for being in violation of the sokovia
Accords and aiding The Escape of
national rebellious hoodlum Steven
Rogers we last seen secretary Ross
during the aftermath of black widow's
final action scene as he and a bunch of
government agents drive towards the
remains of the Hidden Red Room in the
sky littering the fields of Russia this
is significant I feel because the Red
Room wasn't just your ordinary floating
sky base of badass women who could put
you in the hospital oh no I feel like
the Red Room itself is extremely
valuable to government entities like
secretary Thunderbolt Ross and the newly
erected head of the CIA Contessa
Valentina Allegre de Fontaine because
the Red Room had game-changing mind
control sign clients inside of it mainly
because that Red Room leader
drakov was using the secret science data
that Molina and Alexis stole at the very
beginning of the Black Widow movie to
buy and control an army of women
soldiers and arrest their Free Will
science data that was stolen from a
laboratory called the north Institute in
Ohio that was secretly working with
Hydra in the Winter Soldier program as
revealed by Natasha's fake spy science
mother Molina AKA The Iron Maiden who
ended up using that very science to make
the red rooms of Mind Control agent for
drakoff in the first place in
conjunction with the Winter Soldier
project they had dissected and
deconstructed the human brain to create
the first and only cellular blueprint of
the basal ganglia we didn't steal
weaponry
stole the key to unlocking free will now
this is very important because with
secretary Ross and his team of
government agents being the first to
just wreckage at the end of Black Widow
this means that Molina's mind-altering
science of the Red Room is likely in the
hands of Thunderbolt Ross a man who has
pretty much dedicated his entire life to
replicating the super soldier program
for the government and I believe that
this could be a major contributing
factor as to why the members of the
Thunderbolts team a team that I believe
will be named after General Thunderbolt
Ross were chosen the way that they were
because as many people have pointed out
and noticed this MCU Thunderbolts team
is consisted of a bunch of super
soldiers but not just your regular super
soldiers specifically super soldiers who
have had or very likely have had their
minds altered in one way or another and
I think that's a really important
distinction here like for example Elena
and Taskmaster with the Red Room Bucky
Barnes with the Winter Soldier program
with both of those entities of course
tied to the north Institute then we have
John Walker with the super soldier Ciro
making him more crazy then we also see
it with ghosts and the energies from her
dad's Quantum tunnel making her more
mentally unstable over time and also the
Red Guardian very likely had his mind
altered by the Red Room as well with his
entire time as the Red Guardian being a
fake memory planted in his brain by the
Soviet Union using Molina's science now
this is just a wild theory of mine but I
believe that this would explain why the
Red Guardian swears that he has battled
Captain America before Steve Rogers was
even thought out and while Molina had a
mind-controlled pig named Alexi in the
first place because she's mind
controlled and Alexi before
come in
does that pig just open the door yes
good boy Alexi good boy this being said
I'm willing to bed that the Thunderbolts
movie serves as a sequel to Black Widow
in the sense that we are going to see
the continuation of this tale of what it
means to have free will with this team
of people who have been slaves to
various political entities throughout
their entire life I mean hell maybe the
Thunderbolts end up finding out that
they were convinced to join the team
because secretary Ross secretly used
some of that red room mind control Jews
to make them join I don't know something
to think about but anyways at the same
time the Thunderbolts movie will of
course evolve the overall Narrative of
the Superhuman arms race that has been
bubbling up in the MCU since the very
beginning of the MCU during the days of
Edward Norton's Incredible Hulk because
let's be real we are going to see the
Red Hulk in this movie at some point and
I think that secretary Ross potentially
grabbing that Red Room mind control
energy from all that Russian Rubble
could end up leading to his
transformation into the Red Hulk proper
because if you think about it in the MCU
Bruce Banner turned into the Hulk
because General Ross recruited him to
try to recreate Captain America however
the difference between Bruce Banner's
experiments and Abraham erskine's
experiments is that Bruce Banner chose
to use gamma radiation instead of that
Nifty Vita radiation that Abraham
Erskine used on Steam this all being
said what would happen if Red Hulk
decided to use some of that red room
mind-controlled radiation instead of
gamma radiation or Vita radiation with
the help and guidance of one Samuel
Stearns AKA The Leader AKA that
big-headed that we haven't
seen since 2008 I mean we know this
overly curious science geek of a freak
is going to be working with Val in
Captain America new world order right
and we know this weird Man created the
Abomination for shits and giggles right
and we know no that the leader is
responsible for the creation of the Red
Hulk in the comics right that's why I
believe that the combination of all
these factors could potentially point to
the Thunderbolt Ross using the aftermath
of Black Widow to become the Red Hulk
The Ultimate Super Soldier protector of
the planet but much like we learned in
Civil War there is a possibility here
that secretary Ross's road to the
ultimate super soldier was paved with
one or two malfunctioning test subjects
which may lead to the Thunderbolts team
needing to be assembled to take down
some of the leaders failed super
soldiers Conroe you know the very thing
that Captain America Bucky and Iron Man
feared in Civil War but also something
Zemo feared very much as well which I
could see this new superhuman's arms
race forcing Zemo back into the murder
fold as well as he ain't really about
that super soldier life at all he hates
super powered people he does not like
Cubans having the powers of gods we had
another affection of gods amongst real
people super soldiers cannot be allowed
to exist though I could definitely see
Zemo being recruited to the thunderbolts
at least by the very end of the movie
you can follow me at Mass retainment on
Twitter if you guys want to see me tweet
some weird but more importantly you
can follow new Roxas wherever we are on
the social media but yes thank you guys
again for watching this video love you
guys so much and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye